-So you were in a fantastic film
that got wonderful reviews.
"Columbus."
-Oh, yeah. Thank you.
-And that must´ve been --
that you shot that
down in Columbus, Indiana.
-That´s correct.
-I remember you were
off to shoot it
last time you were here.
-Last time, yeah.
Yeah, it´s a very good movie
about two people
that meet in this town called
Columbus, Indiana.
Because of this
industrialist that lives there,
Joseph Irwin,
he just decided
out of civic pride
that they needed to have
world-class architecture.
So it´s just
one after the other,
from churches
to the fire stations
to the elementary schools
to the libraries.
It´s just one masterpiece
after another.
And these two people bond
over their love of architecture.
It´s a fantastic film.
-Congratulations.
And, also, I´ve heard tell
you had a bit of a nude scene.
-Yes. Yeah.
[ Audience "oohs" ]
-Thank you.
Correct response.
[ Laughter ]
-No, thank -- thank you.
-Correct response, yeah.
Correct response.
-[ Laughs ]
It was from the back.
-Uh-huh.
-But...
[ Laughter ]
No.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Incorrect response.
[ Laughter ]
God. [ Laughs ]
I did not see that coming.
I should have. [ Laughs ]
But, yeah, it was from the back.
It was this
very beautiful shower,
and they came to me and said,
"Would you be willing?"
And you know what I decided,
Seth?
I couldn´t think
of an Asian male butt
in American cinema,
and I said,
"Somebody has to do it."
-Oh, that´s fantastic.
So you broke --
[ Cheers and applause ]
You broke the butt line.
-I broke the butt barrier.
-Yeah.
You broke the glass underpants?
[ Laughter ]
But you -- so you have a --
I did not know this
from our time working together.
I guess one of the reasons
I didn´t know this
was we were on such
a low budget film,
we did not have trailers.
-No. [ Laughs ]
-But you have a tradition,
during lunch,
that you do not like
to wear your character´s costume
during lunch.
-I don´t.
So I do get down to my skivvies
at lunch in my trailer.
-And what is it --
is it psychologically
you just want to --
are you worried about spilling
or do you want to, like,
leave the character?
-Mostly I just want to be
myself.
And then I just feel like,
you brush your teeth
and you put on your costume,
and then it´s basically 8:00,
and the show is starting.
-Yeah.
-And so I get undressed.
Sometimes they leave
the microphone on,
so I´m just in my underwear
and an ankle pack.
Microphone on my chest.
But that´s how I eat lunch.
So you´re welcome,
any time you want to drop by.
-And then do people --
[ Laughter ]
Do people ever walk in on you?
Is that something
that ever happens?
-I get the knock,
and I just --
you know, I do one of --
-Okay, gotcha.
-Answer the door like that.
-Yeah, so they can´t tell
that you´re eating.
-That was miming.
-That´s very good.
Your kids are 9 and 14?
-9 and 4.
Right.
No, 14 wouldn´t have made sense.
[ Laughter ]
But you -- how is their
Halloween planning going?
-There is -- I don´t think
I´m going to be there,
but there´s costumes being
purchased over the Amazon.
-Do they come to you
for counsel?
Do they want your take, or are
they very much single-minded
about it?
-No, you know,
my boy in particular
just dreams up crazy outfits.
-So, like, not, like,
existing characters.
-Non-existent.
They don´t shop.
And he´s always been like that,
and because his mother
is an angel, she just executes.
-Oh, so he goes to her and says,
"This is what I´m thinking."
-"This is what I want.
Let´s make it happen."
-Yeah. What is --
like, what sort of thing?
-Well, I think,
his first Halloween,
he said, "I want to be
a Wii-U controller."
-Oh. Okay.
[ Laughter ]
So he wanted to be
a video game controller.
-Remote. Yeah.
And so that was --
So there was just --
there was a panic.
Boxes were purchased.
-Yeah.
-Paint was bought.
-Because that is
that true white-hot panic
of you can go to Amazon
and you can´t find it.
-You can´t find it. Yeah, so.
-So, is your wife craftsy?
Can she kind of, like,
put it together?
-Yeah, I mean, enough.
It was pretty easy to impress
a 5-year-old.
-Yeah, that´s true.
That´s great.
It would be a bummer
if he´s like,
"Oh. I was hoping
for a little, uh,
more accuracy."
-[ Laughs ]
-Well, that´s very exciting.
And always so exciting
to have you here.
Really appreciate it, John.
-Oh, man, always.
-Such a pleasure.
-Thank you so much.
-John Cho, everybody.